évident donc la droite sénatoriale la
majorité du Sénat avec la complicité du
gouvernement a perdu son sang-froid
comme je l'ai dit hier soir sur cet
article 7 ensemble vous ne supportez
plus l'exercice pleinement
constitutionnel du droit d'amendement de
susamment et de l'expression des
parlementaires pour sa part la droite
sénatoriale menée par Monsieur
Retailleau nouveau ministre chargé des
Relations avec le Parlement et madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales et les rapporteurs ont violé le
règlement du Sénat en déclarant
irrecevable des abonnements qui étaient
pourtant pleine ment sur cet article 7
toutes toutes les procédures possibles
et imaginables ont été dégainées par
plusieurs présidents de groupe
favorables à cet article 7 sais-je le
redis la démonstration d'un coup de
force monsieur le Président vous vous
êtes assis sur votre propre règlement et
la prétendue sagesse du Sénat on a pris
un coup c'est une ligne rouge qui a été
franchie elle porte gravement atteinte
aux principes constitutionnels de clarté
et de sincérité des débats votre
objectif c'est de s'assurer l'opposition
à ce projet d'allongement de l'âge de
départ à la retraite à 74 à 64 ans au
cœur de l'article 7 vous avez agi de la
sorte au soir même d'une magnifique
mobilisation du peuple qui ne veut pas
subir deux années de travail
supplémentaire avec le gouvernement vous
tentez d'imposer ce dogme libéral celui
qui prend toujours plus au plus pauvre
pour donner toujours plus au plus riche
avec vos procédures vous avez empêché la
discussion de nos propositions
celle qui vise à renforcer la
participation des revenus des plus aisés
et financiers au financement du régime
de retraite vous n'avez pas voulu
protégeant actionnaires et patronat de
ce débat essentiel sur le partage des
richesses vous battez le débat pour
dissimuler la vérité à nos concitoyens
parmi lesquels vos propres électeurs qui
sont aussi dans la mobilisation à votre
grande âme évidemment monsieur le
Président nous voterons nous votons
contre cet article 7
issu de la corps scellé entre le
gouvernement et la majorité de droite
sénatoriale
Monsieur Olivier
[Musique]